I just think that it's unacceptable to
have the the folks who control the pipes
get into anything that smacks of
controlling the content or favoring
their content over other god whoa if
you're like me you've spent the last few
months pondering one of life's elusive
questions what the hell is net
neutrality I posed this question to Ruiz
an associate editor and resident net
neutrality guru Peter Sirmon who
explained it this way Internet service
providers like AT&T or Comcast should be
required to treat all pieces of
information that pass through their
pipes or over their airwaves equally you
know that sounds pretty good I mean who
could object to everyone being treated
equally on the Internet
it turns out a whole bunch of people
agree like Mallory from family ties what
if there was a show that Time Warner had
coming out that Warner had coming out
they were gonna show online it was very
similar to show I had online and our
show is very successful and maybe and
this is just a supposition maybe they
didn't want that
maybe they turn to me and say unless you
pay us $10,000 a month we're gonna make
the cut of the connection to your
website very slow and then there's that
vegetarian guy who's always getting
beaten up by Eminem fans don't people
know if their ability to download
information from the internet will be
severely compromised if net neutrality
is overturned but when I found out that
Al Gore was a supporter of net
neutrality I started getting a little
suspicious whoa
so according to Malory and Moby the
Internet could be threatened by ISPs
like Comcast and Verizon who might slow
down traffic and may perhaps cut off
access to content they disagree with
ensure it sounds like a terrifying
dystopian future but here's the problem
none of this is actually happening net
neutrality proponents must rely on
hypotheticals because there simply
aren't many examples of supposed
neutrality violations
what a few cases cited as Pearl Jam
frontman Eddie Vedder's anti-bush lyrics
during an AT&T sponsored web stream the
company cut out the political statements
sudirman explains it shouldn't happened
and everybody knows it shouldn't happen
it was it was a myth you know it was a
human error it wasn't policy but other
than that there very very few examples
let's say that net neutrality activists
succeed in regulating the Internet just
who would do the regulating it seems
that job would fall to the FCC one thing
that's particularly problematic with the
FCC's stance on that neutrality is that
what they're proposing in addition to
the guidelines is a call it as they see
it standard so that there's no
particular set of rules instead the art
the FCC will get to be the arbiter of
what is okay and what isn't on a
case-by-case basis so they want the FCC
the Janet Jackson Nipplegate people the
people who find bono for saying to
regulate the internet rather than
getting government bureaucracy involved
in a problem that doesn't yet exist
sudirman suggests we stick to the market
which has worked exceptionally well so
far is peas aren't perfect but at least
they're subject to market pressures the
government on the other hand is subject
primarily to political pressures most of
the impetus for net neutrality is a
result of political pressure big
influential actors pushing the
government to do what they want to
protect their business models look it's
because the internet isn't shackled by
government regulations that is expanded
it's such a rapid rate and it's because
of the profit motive that access to
high-speed broadband has exploded in
recent years increased regulation when
no one can even point to real-world
examples of ISPs infringing on network
neutrality runs the very real risk of
stifling innovation in slowing future
growth so let's take a page from Al Gore
whoa and slow down and wait until
there's a real problem before we start
discussing regulation for reason TV I'm
Michael Moynihan